was fällt mit sand und wasser zwei enden
was fängt an und beschreibt ein witz
ziemlich kacke allem ein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen hier heute meine
damen und herren zu einer neuen episode
von lukas leute stunde bei lukas noll
stunde geht es darum dass meine
community di luca auf instagram unter
dem hashtag luca irgendwelche dummen
witze hochgeladen hat die ich mir jetzt
anschauen werde
schwindel ihn
das sind ja die wii
die lustiger
treffen sich hause uns niemand sagt der
hase wäre oder fühlen
dafür wurde das ist weiß und stört beim
essen eine lawine
wo
hofers lustig was ist der unterschied
zwischen wasser und lehrer wasser ist
flüssig und lehrer sind überflüssig
unterhalten sich zwei person stelle man
den ofen einen doofen du bist
eingestellt
an machen offen hatte schon was vor
das echt ganz armes deutschland warum
haben elefanten solange rüssel weil sie
ist edel fanden
ich weiß echt nicht was ich zu diesen
witzen sagen soll
aus dem brennenden haus war überhaupt
nicht witzig geht man eine luke der lapt
doppelte abgaben nicht ganz ehrlich das
war der erste witz wo ich ein wenig
schmunzeln musste doppelt hat weil ich
einmal deppe und halt einen deppen
erhalte ohne handy auf die toilette
haben 105 fließen
was built by am besten mit einem blinden
ich sehe was was du nicht warum
egal das ist einfach eine beleidigung
das doch kein witzen würde wollte mit
heißen wenn holz eine waldorfschule wäre
der das name nicht getanzt werden da
relativer wisst bin ich ganz ehrlich
aber halt ich also nicht so witzig
ein ball loser und an den platz der arm
nach oben ich wirklich gleich
bleibt dabei wird vom arm losen ich
trete ich gleich
dann verkündet das möchte ich ihn
einfach
klug an einer wand vorbei schreibt lauf
auf und sagte was ist das denn für ein
hässliches bild an dessen wand der opern
antwort thüle
das war ein spiegel
entweder ist der witz kacke oder ich
werde fertig gemacht und will nicht
darüber lachen man eine fred der alles
geriet
alfred
also ja ich verstehe den witz alfred
aber hey das macht doch keinen sinn wenn
schon müsste es irgendwie so heißen ja
wie man einen fred der astronaut ist
alfred warum luca reden meinte
city-coach ausgeben muss war oracle
klasse aber freude ich hab gelacht
wahnsinn dass wir das aber schafft in
diesem format also wenn ihr bessere
witzel kennt dann folgt wir gerne auf
instagram und postet ein video mit
irgendeiner zweit seite von euch jedoch
so viel zu eurem account nicht damit zu
wollen mit unter dem hashtag lugano wo
ihr ein witz erzählt ihr könnt auch wie
gesagt einfach eure wand filmen oder
euren fuß es geht nur darum das ist ein
vernünftiger ist allerdings mache ich
mir schon gedanken darüber diese serie
zu beenden
es konnten nur dort harz laible plan
diene mit dem auto quer durch die
nächste was macht ihr wenn ihr heiß wird
sie macht einfach das fenster auf das
ist ja echt überhaupt nicht lustig und
man eine traurige tasse ok meine damen
und herren wir haben hier bisher den
heutigen in der woche wie nennt man eine
traurige tasse
die presse finde ich sehr sehr gut sehr
kreativ ich weiß nicht wollte den witz
hast auch wenn du dir selbst überlegt
hat herzlichen glückwunsch
hast du aber glaube ich nicht ihnen
austauschen kloster richtig kloster hose
sie nennt man einen witz
komplett beschützen sagte er das ist die
kinder gucken
ich glaube ich gut der arzt hatte denn
sagt er sie hatte ja keine ahnung
geschmeckt einfach kommen
schmeckt komisch sagten asiate mit
seinem hund beim arzt
das ist heute die folge der beleidigung
ich entschuldige mich dafür ist
natürlich alles nur spaßeshalber hier
die ganzen witze von den leuten das
eingesendet haben was ich glaube keiner
von denen möchte wirklich irgendjemand
beleidigen
falls sich doch jemand beleidigt fühlt
tut mir leid keine freunde ist die
wahrheit
ist
und nicht lustig das headset am und im
wasser
was fängt mit zittern und beschreibt ein
witz ziemlich karg aber erst werden hier
leute ohne arme beleidigt dann leute die
nicht sehen können dann asiaten und
jetzt noch ikea leute fahrt ein wenig
zurück was braucht ein blinder im
schwimmbad ein seehund einen seehund
oh gott das hat er nicht gesagt ein
blinder im schwimmbad brauchen seehund
wow
feiner sand das eigentlich gesagt
das hat er nicht gesagt
7 mal 7
münchen das berger genommen hat
stehlampe ein glühwürmchen das viagra
genommen hat stehlampe
ich könnte im strahl gegen meine softbox
kotzen allerdings sehe ich gerade hat
noch ein zweites vorbereitetes plätzchen
geht denn den abfüllern sind 15 trittin
hütchen und wie 40 15
fritzchen holt sich kaum noch ab
bei 15 äpfel dranhängen
hängen immer noch 15 apple dran also da
musste ich ja wirklich richtig loslassen
ja dann auch
aus
juni direkt mit kommen war gut dann
kriegen sie doch gleich mitkommen hoher
preis heute geht wieder vorkommen an den
fakten zu trimmen konsolen so betrunken
war ich doch gar nicht sagte dort den
duschkopf in den arm genommen und gesagt
er soll aufhören zu weinen
was ist jetzt so lustig daran wenn man
eine dusche trösten will wie nennt man
ein russischen veganer moskauer leute
bin ich ganz ehrlich der witz ist nicht
schlecht aber auch nicht gut
so wie mein kanal eigentlich zu tun hat
auf einer studie eine frau wie können
und war gerade der rauchmelder geht
nicht an luca fragt verwirrt flow darauf
die frau leide nicht ob es
warum
was hat dich dein freund zu den anderen
und du ich glaube diese tomatis
radioaktiv verstrahlt die tomate wie
kommen für den darf tomatis radioaktiv
verstrahlt und sie redet mit dem
das heute und ich weiß das sag ich nach
jeder folge aber wirklich die mit
abstand günstigste
aneinanderreihung von witzen
je gesehen habe wenn euch meine reckte
jedoch trotzdem gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch
von euch freuen schreibt mir gern witze
unten in die kommentare oder noch viel
lieber auf instagram video hochladen
unter dem hashtag luca leute gern auch
wenn du ihr euren schreibtisch filmt
oder mit einer breitseite viel hochladen
oder so wie mir einfach irgendein
lustigen witze 1 sendet
leute ich meinen
es kann ja eigentlich nicht so schwer
sein
[Musik]